hello everyone and welcome to the active
inference live stream
this is active inference live stream
13.1 and it is january 5th
2021. happy new year everyone
welcome to the active inference lab
the active inference lab is an
experiment in online team communication
learning and practice related to active
inference
feedback you can find us at our website
twitter
email youtube or key based teams this is
a recorded in an archived live stream
so please provide us with feedback so we
can improve our work
all backgrounds and perspectives are
welcome here and keep in mind video
etiquette for live streams
for 2021 we are going to be meeting
every tuesday regularly at 7 to 9 a.m
pacific time
and then we'll plan other special
sessions as things come up and for
different time zones
you can go to this link and see a
spreadsheet and here we are in the first
week with the first paper and next week
we'll be discussing the same one
so hello everyone thanks for coming on
live and thanks everybody who's watching
let's introduce ourselves please give a
short introduction or check in
especially if it's your first time on
the stream and then pass it to somebody
who hasn't spoken so i'm daniel i'm in
davis and i'll pass it to colin
i'm colin de young and i'm in
minneapolis minnesota
i'm a professor in the psychology
department here at the university of
minnesota
and excited to be here um i'll
pass it on to stephen
hello i'm stephen i'm based in toronto
and i'm doing my practice based phd at
canterbury christchurch university
and uh pleased to be here as well
i'm gonna pass it to shannon
hey i'm shannon crooks i'm
in south dakota so also in the snow but
i'm based at the university of
california in merced
during my phd also i'll pass it to marco
hi i'm marco um i'm from holland and
used to
work on active influence in london but
now i'm just
um enjoying the progress from the
sidelines
i'll pass it to uh ivan
thank you my name is ivan i'm from
russia from moscow and i'm interested in
free energy principle and as it related
with
systems engineering and i pass it to
excuse me what is your name my friend
dave let's go to dave hi
dave douglas i'm retired from
information technology i live in the
philippines
and i did about equal amounts of
graduate level work in computer science
linguistics and psychology
but have only a lowly ba
cool let's go to blue and then adam
hi good morning everyone my name is blue
knight and
i am an independent research consultant
based out of new mexico
and adam welcome
hi i'm adam uh sorry i'm late
i am based out of
bloomington indiana uh i'm a
post-doctoral researcher cool
well welcome everyone thanks so much for
coming on
filling out the hollywood square that we
have here
for these warm-up questions it'll be
great to hear from everyone just
raise your hand if you have a thought
i'll just put up the first two
totally just raise your hand as you want
to add something
first would be what is something about
human personality or
emotions that you would want to see
captured in
a good model or understanding or
education
and then also what is something that you
liked
or remembered about the paper
and um i think there was a few memorable
parts
of the paper just while people are
raising their hand
uh i think just the idea of going from a
statistical
understanding of the big five as
principal component dimensions
to being the outputs of a cybernetic
system is really an interesting
topic so maybe
if uh anyone wants to raise their hand
on this one
or adam or colin
maybe how do you go about introducing
uh the the need for your kind of paper
to an audience like where do you start
out with the interesting part about
personality that you want to capture
in your model
well uh shall i jump in then yeah
and when you say raised hand do you mean
this little button here or
you can like actually just wave at the
screen probably with the button
all right works that works
um so uh one of the things that i
noticed in your
summary of the paper was something that
i
often encounter from people working in
other scientific fields
which is a certain degree of skepticism
about
the big five because of their origin in
uh natural language and
um and because you know when you see a
diagram that's like a hierarchy of
personality traits
i you know in a figure there i was
careful to note that that is not
supposed to be a diagram of causal
structure in the individual because
there's this interesting problem where
we use the same visual language for
causal models of you know boxes and
circles and arrows
and for statistical models in which
we're looking at the relationships among
variables but obviously those are not
directly
translatable and
so the way that i would pose the basic
question that's of interest here is
why do certain traits of people tend to
cluster together
i think that that's really the core of
what i'm interested in
and what we're interested in if we're
talking about the sources of personality
a lot of personality research in the
last 40 years
or so since the big five demerged as
kind of an organizing consensus
framework
has really been focused on questions of
prediction like if we have these
assessments of people's personality
tendencies
what kind of outcomes does it predict
for them
um also potentially like what are
trajectories of uh
change and development of these things
over time but i'm interested in a
question that
is a lot less studied which is where
these patterns come from in the first
place
and so i think the way that to think
about the kind of statistical element
here is simply that
there is an observation that if we have
a large set of descriptions
of uh people's personality and it
doesn't have to be
from the natural language that was just
one good source for a relatively
unbiased set of descriptions
of people was to go into the dictionary
and just pull out the adjectives that
could describe people
um but we see a very similar pattern of
factors like the big five if we start
with a lot of say existing personality
questionnaires that weren't designed to
measure the big five you throw them all
together
you still get the big five so as long as
we have a sufficiently
large set of descriptions of personality
and we have ratings on them
they tend to cluster together in
reliable ways and
as long as they are valid you know as
long as when we say that somebody's
talkative that really does mean that
they talk more than other people do
and there's a lot of evidence for the
basic levels of validity
of personality ratings then the question
is
why is it that people who are talkative
also tend to
be uh more sociable also tend to
experience
more positive emotions also tend to be
more physically active
also tend to be uh let's say more
interested in
excitement and uh dangerous um
you know risky pursuits so we've got a
whole bunch of things that cluster
together and the question is why
um and so you know that was a list of
low-level traits that are grouped
together within extraversion
and that's just a statistical
observation those people who tend to
have
more of one of those things also tend to
have more of another and so i see
fundamentally
the question that i'm interested in is
what are the underlying
mechanisms that vary from person to
person
that drive these patterns of
co-occurrence of particular
characteristics
thank you for that shannon
thanks for that um really nice sort of
overview introduction
um i was sort of wondering going through
this paper
you talk about what are the differences
that are
can be ascribed to individuals and their
individual personalities
that lead to you know traits like
extroversion or what have you
um but what if there is nothing
unique to any individual that gives rise
to a personality trait
and i wonder where does um culture and
social interaction
fit into this kind of model
and that's just a question that i'm
interested in throughout
the next couple of hours that we're here
today
nice good question anyone i put up also
the third one blue
so something as i was wondering about
like as i was reading the paper
was you know the big five personality
and like
it's um you know grounded in genetic
uh influences right um
but like attachment theory and like
there's like a bunch of work that's been
done in mice like showing like you know
the nurturing of parents
and you know whether you're attachment
avoidant or attachment anxious
or um you know attachment secure that's
also something i think would be fun and
interesting to
um model in in the free energy kind of
way like put into this framework
and i think it has like some cool um
you know impacts for like team building
and and how
um you know like whether i don't know i
just think it'd be it would be
interesting and maybe
um impactful in in this kind of
framework
cool and blue to that point i just saw a
paper this uh
morning from anna sunica at all and axel
constant
the first prior from co-embodiment to
co-homeostasis in early life
about this transition from like a truly
in utero
embedded being to different types of
physiological
dependencies social and cultural so it
is interesting to think about
all right we have an individual
orientation around the big five
it's about the individual in
relationship to different types of
settings
but then how do you capture that element
of niche construction
or of group dynamics or of these other
aspects that are
relational i'm just curious colin or or
adam like where does the uh
other how does that enter into it this
idea of the
cultural influences in on personality
because someone's personality might be
manifested in a really specific setting
because of
their local context oh i could just say
something about that that is relevant i
think to both of the two questions that
have just been
asked uh which is just to keep in mind
that
um these personality traits are
descriptions of
uh you know persistent patterns of
people's behavior
and we know that they are genetically
influenced but we also know that they're
not
entirely determined by genetics they are
also determined by environmental
influences
and so the way that i think about this
is that you have these uh you know these
mechanisms that are
allowing people to function and some
parameters of those mechanisms
must be reasonably persistent to produce
these persistent patterns of behavior
but the the things that set those
parameters and that tweak them if
there's change in personality over time
can be both uh genetically
programmed and environmentally
programmed right so there are things
there are events that happen to people
for example their relations to their
primary caregiver and attachment that
shape what these settings are going to
be persistently
in life and so i think there's
definitely room for
thinking about environmental inputs uh
to these systems
and shaping of these parameters uh as
well as genetic ones
ooh and colin at this point you raised
earlier about
graphical models and just drawing a
connection
among different variables is that a
causal model is that a statistical model
are those different what if you're
talking about causal entropy or you're
doing a
causal uh you know model like a
structural equation modeling
or even if it's a linear aggression it's
going to be interpreted as a causal
influence and
they'll put in the discussion oh it
could be a different way it could just
be correlation but
it's really hard to disentangle that um
yeah marco
hi thanks um so first of all uh i
haven't really read the paper
kind of recently got out of a pandemic
slumber
um but but it sounds very interesting
from what i've read and heard so far
and as for the first question about what
i'd like to see it might be a bit
um in the far future but i think ideally
um this would all
connect sooner or later to the work on
neuro phenomenology
the kind of ideal vision i have is for
example now we've been talking about
genetic priorities and environmental
inputs
but i think the beautiful part about
cybernetics is the kind of reflexive
action
and so consciousness or phenomenology
is basically a mediator or moderator of
the way that's
environmental inputs kind of influence
our continuing progression
of personality or um traits and and
characteristics
and so ideally um i would love to see a
well i would love to hear if it's
possible to make a synthesis of for
example
the work from psychoanalysis
psychotherapy everything that kind of
uh explores and navigates these
particular mechanisms
from a first person kind of view how to
navigate the experience
of being engaged in the world and i'm
just wondering about
adam's or conan someone else's thoughts
on how to possibly connect
that phenomenological description of
mechanisms and processes
with the more formal basic models that
we're
now exploring in this kind of work if
that makes sense
yeah very nice adam and then anyone else
uh hello can you hear me yep yeah great
um so i guess uh uh try to
address a couple of things um
so yeah uh yeah marco just thrust us
into like the deepest possible territory
like right away
um and so i guess i'll briefly comment
on that uh
second but it's the first thing in terms
of um
social context and
uh niche construction and the more
intersubjective
aspects and contexts um sensitivity of
personality
uh active inferential modeling is really
well equipped to
address all of that uh in this paper it
was more
uh the focus was just kind of exploring
what uh
colin and i both perceive to be a very
rich set of correspondences between
the free energy principle and active
inference and uh
his theory of cybernetic big five theory
but on
um modeling work you can
uh bring in all of those details and
explore them in their particular so
i'm currently collaborating on a project
where we're trying to model things like
extroversion
within these um social choice tasks and
so
how you show up it's going to be a
function
of you know both the task environment
and you
as this interaction that's going to
evoke a given
style of pattern but you'll have these
um parameters uh
these hyper priors are over
the different aspects of the generative
model
which through iterated policy selection
and uh updating will basically
concentrate their probability mass in
different ways
and result in different
parameterizations and then different
emergent behavior and what you can see
happen is you can get
these basically attractors formed as
this process proceeds over time
these behavioral attractors where you
the concentration of your prior for
engaging in the world in a certain way
causes you to enact a given pattern
which causes you to
even more update in that direction like
your your d matrix like where am i in
this environment
uh you know what do you expect to be
perceiving your a matrices all the
different like components that you use
to try to
model the parts of an agent these are
all your priors of these will get
updated
will then cause the pattern of action so
on and so forth and that
over time this could cause you to be in
this attractor where you have this
enduring stability um how enduring you
know it would depend on
a variety of things uh and
but so i guess that's one so in this
process
uh the social context who you're
interacting with
that would make all the difference in
terms of like how the kind of ball
rolls down this epigenetic landscape
like how you end up like
carving out a given pattern for this
agent
uh with respect to uh neurophenomenology
and just the uh actually getting
the richness of experience
there's a sense in which all active
inferential modeling is already in a way
um kind of personality modeling
it's like you're kind of getting into
like um
these enduring um you know
the cybernet what they're thinking them
as these like cyber data
parameters for this fundamental process
um
or just the your ability to describe
um the essence of the system uh the
it's it's normal form description this
this maximally encompassing a
description of the modes of where you
expect
to find the system as a kind of
probabilistic density in some kind of
multi-dimensional phase space if you
have such a
attracting network structure that you
can describe in a way you could call
that the personality of the system
um but cybernetic big five theory um
kind of goes further
and uh or it it's grounding this in
terms of well
why should we expect certain modes
over others why should we expect that
relates it back to this fundamental
cybernetic cycle of gold pursuit that
any agent has to do
um so with respect to neurophenomenology
and
it seems like the attempts to get at
this within active inference things like
uh sophisticated effective inference the
the models of uh
metacognition where they're beginning to
model like kinds of mindful processing
of reflecting on your um
your confidence and and then this
influencing your
uh you you
having an actual model of your epistemic
status
you reflect you're reflecting on this
and this influencing how you sample
influencing
uh how confident you are in different
ways um influencing what policies you
end up
deploying these things that to the
extent that
they allow for um phenomenological
richness
they could be brought into an agent
model
and you're beginning to do a connection
between neurophenomenology
or a process theory of that wood dock of
phenomenology
and personality modeling so those are
some thoughts
nice thanks and to add on that adam
because that was really
well said it's almost like some of these
past papers we've been discussing
were the neutral infrastructure or the
architecture or the tools
to have agents that can have memory or
can have affect or
can perceive valence or get worried so
we talked that in a very neutral
framework like it's a parameter in the
model however in the real world
as colin was getting at there's these
extremely deep
correlations with different outcomes of
systems people who like to text more
also like to video chat more or
something
and that might not be surprising but it
these trends are
very distinct and so we are getting at
this generative
model idea personality as a generator
of outcomes in different niches so
inseparable from the niche
and um it's just an interesting
way to see how the cybernetic big five
has come from a more psychological area
so it has uh that sort of um
toe of the neurophenomenology and the
real correlations in the world
and then there's the neutral framework
that sort of maps onto that
we have stephen and then colin
yeah i like what's been said about
neurophenomenology and i'd also
say that one of the things that's good
about the this this work with traits
is it it's starting to bring work that's
coming from
um what you could say realist settings
codifying it and then finding the
patterns
and it's giving us more material coming
the other way we've had some work around
a lot of work with affordances and
niches and then obviously you've got the
models which start to create
dynamics and show and then you start to
see where these two things meet
but i would also say micro i've been
looking a lot of micro phenomenology
and the actual structuring of experience
and attention
and i think that um what can be
interesting is these traits if these
traits can also get brought down into
micro phenomenology
and ways of like how is
the structure of the environment body
mind
um happening and and where
are there times because what i think
with a lot of the trait works is it does
have a normative assumption about the
type of life someone's in
around which you then standardize
and then get these patterns but you do
find if you take
people into some other types of space or
other types of attentional state
be a more grounded state maybe a
performative state maybe a
space which is less western so to speak
less gold orientated um that might shift
so this might be like this is where that
is when people are at this normative
mediated uh sort of normative like
calculated way of getting everyone
that's like the goal directed norm for a
westerner
um and then can these different
components to that be sort of treated
and also looked at how do they vary
as we move like not just as the fire but
in you know as
individual kind of um tap
ways to tap into affordances when do
these change more or less when we bring
people into another type of
way of a regime of attention or another
set of performances which is outside the
normal
for our cultural goal-driven
way of being in the west okay
colin and then marco i just had a couple
of thoughts about
uh phenomenology since that's been a
theme um
recently um first of all i think one
interesting thing
to think about in relation to uh trait
approaches is that when we do
assessments of personality using
self-report questionnaires
you know which is not the only way that
you can do it of course you can have
other people
you know rate the personality of
somebody and we tend to see very similar
results if we use other people's ratings
versus self ratings
um although there's also evidence that
there's some incremental validity there
in other words
you know things about yourself that
other people don't know so that there's
some unique validity to your reports
but other people also know things about
you that you don't know so there's also
some unique validity to other people's
reports on your personality
but as long as we're talking about the
self reports then that is at base a kind
of
you know crude phenomenological measure
right because you're saying
what are you like what is your
experience of yourself like are you the
kind of person who's anxious
are you the kind of person who likes art
you know and we get
a long list of people's responses on
these things and then we
infer their general patterns of behavior
from them and so i do think you know one
of the things that i've always been
interested in is that personality is not
just patterns of
behavior from a third person perspective
it's also patterns of experience
from a first person perspective and so
when we look at the contents of
personality questionnaires you know they
involve descriptions of emotion
and types of cognition and patterns of
motivation
that can all be experienced you know
phenomenologically in the first person
as well and so we're using this kind
of first person representation and
understanding of ourselves to then try
to infer these general patterns of
behavior that have validity
from an objective third person
perspective as well
and then just in terms of like drilling
down to this kind of micro phenomenology
idea
we do know things about particular
patterns of processing that are
associated with different
personality traits uh so for example we
just published a paper showing that
extroversion is associated with the
tendency to be influenced by
uh reward in an implicit learning
context
right so you're doing a task where
you're making this like discrimination
between two very similar options
um and you're rewarded more
for getting correct responses to one
option relative to the other well what
you see is that
people's behavior becomes biased toward
that option
but the degree it becomes biased is
actually correlated with extroversion
and that's part of how we
you know have support for the theory
that fundamentally what
causes all of these different
extroverted behaviors to cohere
is sensitivity to reward and so you can
think of that from the third person as
like here's a process of
you know reward mapping
but you can also think well what is it
like from the for this individual
this is the kind of person who's going
to be more uh perceptive of
possibilities
for uh rewarding interactions for
incentives
in their environment so i think you can
always sort of flip back and forth
between taking the
phenomenological and the more uh
third-person perspective on these things
cool thanks marco
yeah uh thanks actually um kind of ties
into that because i was kind of
wondering if you could share some
thoughts on the relation between value
systems such as
pragmatic value or affect and epistemic
salience and curiosity
with this uh model of personality for
example uh
i did read the jews that the fundamental
components are
um the goal the interpretation and the
strategy right
um and i would say that that value i
mean i would guess that value is more
about
the interpretation right so that you
have some kind of scalar or some other
dimension by which you can compare
certain current
real states and expected states um
and tie into that uh i guess it's a
separate question
but i think i guess i'm going back to
the personality and phenomenology
because maybe you could share some
thoughts and to what extent
personality can be seen as an as a
natural consequence
of the cybernetic imperative where
consciousness has
basically instrumentalized to be the
regulator of
the entire mind body system as it were
because i guess i have some image a
picture of
regimes of reflexive attention right so
there must be some cybernetic
system or set of systems an ecosystem if
you will
um that's regulating or controlling the
entire mind body system
or large portions of it but that in
itself then has to
necessarily by free energy or active
inference have to have some kind of
um uh imperative to decide
or policies to pick and how to engage
with that
bigger mind-body ecosystem if that makes
sense beautiful thank you adam
and then anyone else
darn it marco uh that was awesome yeah
that was epic it wasn't
and then sasha and then we'll leave the
warm-up uh
so i guess uh
two things kind of or a few things
coming to mind um
so i really like this idea of thinking
of
um your consciousness as a
as a kind of modeling for the sake of
cybernetic control
and uh with hopefully you know some
degree of
not perfect but some degree of fidelity
for modeling that which is modeled a
good regular theorem to regulate a
system you have to have a decent enough
model
[Music]
the and so there's a sense in which
um towards this end
uh being able to
have your modeling process reflect on
itself
and model itself uh that that could be a
very useful thing uh if you get it right
um and a very bad thing if you get it
wrong um
the and so it relates to things like
and it could even be that you know these
parameter tunings for these
they might stripe it across like
multiple levels
of abstraction something like curiosity
so you could have like a kind of
um uh curiosity that has a phenomenology
in terms of the way like
a physicist would describe it as like a
phenomenological description of behavior
that's just like showing the emergent
behavior and this looks like a more
curious system in the way it's like
sussing out state space then you might
also get to like
the curiosity in terms of the
what it feels like to be curious and
what those those
motivations those free energy gradients
are going to try to annihilate
those different sources of desire of
pull
um what that's like experientially
and so yeah it seems like something like
curiosity would be reflected at multiple
levels of organization
uh maybe even some weird shifts in terms
of like the way it shows up across
levels of analysis um
the a few
other ideas are coming to mind would be
um there seems to be a sense in which
if so we're talking about you know
someone reporting on
their experience um you can think of
these reports both in terms of
the uh perceptual inferences
that are uh going into them and then the
report is a kind of action it's a kind
of act of inference
and uh each of these aspects you know
for
instance like you could set up a
generative model for each of these and
you would have for instance a
given kind of uh you know
matrix to describe the perception like
given a given set of
observations what's the state that you
then infer and so
this could be like some aspects of like
so what is an
agent what is a person uh noticing in
different circumstances and so this is
like
what is what is it in particular that is
entering into their experience where
does their attention go
you could also have like their attention
not just in terms of a sort of like
uh a salience but a kind of like
active curiosity and a a sampling from
the environment is a kind of mental act
and so this then will influence like
what's getting fed into the stream of
experience and
what it's like to be a particular kind
of agent
kind of particular kind of person in a
particular kind of situation
um those are some thoughts
cool we'll return to that idea about
being in the
niche for a particular kind of agent
we'll do sasha and then call in with the
last word on the intro
awesome yeah thank you um really great
conversation i've already reduced my
uncertainty
and a lot of the questions i came in
with um
uh thank you colin for explaining that
behavior is not the same thing as
personality
because that's something i was starting
to wonder
so it's yeah relevant that personality
uh contains as part of it the
self-report of the
um individual's experience um
and then i like what you said about your
most recent work that sounds really
interesting and kind of falls in line
with
active inference uh
as reducing uncertainty about our
environment and so it seems that
uh extroverts and introverts have a
different sensitivity to
um sense sensitivity to precision
about their world where extroverts are
more
sensitive to reward and
updating their generative model from the
external inputs
like mainly i'm thinking social but of
course could be other things
um so that's an interesting how it fits
into this model
of active inference as well and um i
guess my last thought
is is there another level up
um here where we can talk about people
who
are also sensitive to precision
about personality tests and others
quantified self
um whether there's a metric for that
kind of like self-reflection
part of it um and if that
i think sometimes that can seem a bit
like
a self-fulfilling prophecy but like i
know i'm the kind of person who does
this
so i expect this personality test to
tell me this
um where you're actually not sensitive
to
new information you just want a kind of
confirmation
on what you already think so oh yeah
okay interesting stuff colin and then
we're gonna move to the next section
okay so quickly then just a couple of
thoughts on the last
couple of comments um so first of all
you raise something sasha that is
important which is that personality
tests are certainly
fallible right they're not a great form
of measurement they're just the best
form of measurement we have for
assessing people's personalities
and the reason for that is that it's
really hard to get at an assessment of
people's persistent patterns
in all of their you know different
aspects of functioning
uh with anything other than relying on
people to tell you about it right you
could try to come up with
you know like some complex set of tasks
and people come into the lab and do all
these things and you videotape them and
somehow that's gonna you're gonna
extract all the information about their
personality from that by a carefully
chosen set of things that you have them
go through
you know it'd be a huge amount of work
and you'd be learning less about what
they're like in general than just asking
them a bunch of questions
so you know this is always a perennial
problem it's like well there are these
difficulties with self-reports people
have biases
they uh you know they are motivated to
think of themselves as being
more desirable in various ways than they
are from a you know social desirability
perspective
uh and so what what can you do about
that and
yeah there are certainly studies of you
know the degree to which people are
accurate in their personality assessment
and like the degree to which if they
assess their own personality how much
does that agree with other people's
assessments of their personality
and larger discrepancies can be
predictive of things sometimes
of psychological problems um so there's
a you know there's a whole
area of studying that um but i think i
like this idea of
people who have curiosity about their
own personalities
and that kind of leads into something i
just wanted to say generally about
personality which is that
definitely extroversion is related to
this kind of curiosity about things that
are potentially
rewarding but if we think about
curiosity more generally
as a sensitivity to the reward value of
information per se
so just essentially the motivation to
improve the quality of our
interpretations of the world in terms of
that
language of interpretations and goals
and strategies then
we have a there's a pretty clear sense
that
curiosity of that sort of general form
is the core of one of the big five
traits so the openness to experience an
intellect dimension of the big five
is really focused on people's curiosity
and hunger for information essentially
whether that be more about aesthetic and
perceptual
information related to openness to
experience or whether it's
related to abstract information related
to intellectual
issues so that that seems to be one of
the really core dimensions of
people's personalities so i do think
there's a there's a very clear way to
connect that into this idea of
you know foraging for uh for information
and
seeking out increased entropy for the
sake of reducing entropy
uh over time you know which is what
learning is essentially
so there are good connections there
definitely
interesting and adam just one quick last
note
uh so yeah quickly um
as before we temporarily close off the
phenomenology thread
um it seems like there's a really uh
rich kind of bi-directional relationship
between uh personality science and
active inference
and that uh with personality science you
actually have this
like like they're all basically these
um from the personality modelers i met
they're all these very like integrative
generalists approaching this hair ball
of a problem from as many ways as they
can
and basically bootstrapping themselves
to validity and reliability
and so they've come up with a really
rich literature of
phenomena to populate the phenomenology
and active inference provides the sort
of like places where
you want to kind of dig in deeper onto
like well what is the exact like
causal mechanism it's like cybernetic
big five theory was probably the like
best um in personality science of
getting a causal processes of like how
you're uh
where are these traits coming from and
what are they actually doing for the
agent
so now you can bring an active inference
and describe
agents of cybernetic systems run
simulations
uh generate things that would correspond
to different aspects of
personality like for instance the
dopamine system and curiosity
you now can modify your parameter over
policy selection
and see what then unfolds with respect
to both overt acts or
mental acts like attentional shifts um
so there's just one final thing before
you go the next part is
uh there's some uh in the paper
we start to talk about this idea of like
a piece truck
um or like this kind of object that
could be used
in something like compute computational
psychiatry for
um kind of pooling data over multiple
multiple people to like come up with
um basically a general personality model
that you can deploy
for different agents um
we might want to go into the weeds on
that later um to the extent we can but
the
thing i want to get is that uh the one
thing to model an active inference
is we are all personality modelers
it's like we are all necessarily like
super forecasters trying to predict the
future
we are all also personality modelers
trying to predict each other
and ourselves and part of this would be
towards us and well what kind of agent
do i think i am
what do i think my personality is like
what do i think is going to be
either more situation like what's going
to be enduring
uh what's going to be you can have
personality be enduring but
variable so what's going to be uh how
variable are these
aspects of me how likely are they to
endure these are the questions you have
to ask of yourself and other agents in
order to
govern the interactions and the best of
your ability well said
adam it really just highlights how much
people even though we say things like
well we don't know even given someone's
personality we don't know what they're
gonna do it's like
yeah but you know what language they're
gonna speak and so in the broad scheme
of things you've actually reduced your
uncertainty quite a lot
and if you're not 99.9 aligned with that
agent who's like you
in the niche sharing an interface with
you that
conflict or adversarial relationship or
just
risk surface is going to spiral and so
it's all about this interface yeah marco
if you want to go ahead
yeah thanks i'm sorry i didn't get get
the fire on the paper but that was
really interesting i just briefly
skimmed
the section on it so so it sounds like
the p structure is
basically allowing for a heuristic
contextual dependency
so they have the generic genetic models
of your being
and the p structure kind of links the
current context
to the generic uh kind of models and
that allows for the
variation over different situations i
mean and emphasizing the heuristic
nature of it
because personality basically can be
seen as a very useful
heuristic for how to act in the world
does that make sense or should i
just read more in the paper no i think
that's really
a great uh connection there and a setup
i think in figure two or when we see the
graphical model maybe let's think about
where the structure would play in
and then emphasize its role as a
statistical construct that reduces our
uncertainty about regularities in the
world
just like every other kind of
statistical modeling framework
does um and then i think we'll be able
to come back to that p-struct question
but what a fun uh warm-up
section good times so in
today we did the introductions and
warm-up and then
we'll have the sections of this paper
which may be if you're listening you've
read or not
and that is the integrating cybernetic
big five theory with free energy
principle a new strategy for modeling
personalities as complex systems
by saffron and young both of whom are on
this call
so in this set of slides we do have
a bunch of uh the abstract roadmap some
other stuff but i think there are so
many interesting threads we've
raised let's just try to walk through
all of them
um in no specific order but really think
about what topics do we want to
highlight
for next week when we talk about the
same paper
and how will we get deeper into some of
these threads that we've raised today in
the discussion
so here's the aims and claims slide and
adam or
colin um what
was just your intention with the paper
and after
doing it where do you see the next
implications of the paper or the next
research directions for
what you kind of want to do in that
direction and if that verges into some
of the figures just
mention it and i'll go to that figure
um well i think that our basic
motivation for doing it was just that we
had already been talking together about
topics of mutual interest and the
opportunity to write this chapter came
up and i thought oh this would be a
really fun thing to
uh a good excuse to do something with
adam and kind of get our thoughts
together and
you know actually uh written down and
out there in the world
um and so you know i think
he and i probably have slightly
different incentives for where this is
going next
um he's more interested in the process
processes of modeling whereas i'm more
interested
in you know generating knowledge about
the specific mechanisms and uh you know
brain processes that underlie different
personality traits and risks for
different types of psychopathology that
are tied to different personality traits
um but um yeah i think i mean to me this
is just a really nice way to kind of
connect
um my thinking about personality with
this uh
what seems to me to be an a really
generative perspective with the whole uh
fep framework and what's happening with
that in science in general
i'm sure adam has some other thoughts
about that too
yeah go for it adam but that was very
interesting colin thanks
oh i mean for me that was primarily the
thing like
colin and i were already kind of going
into the weeds together and
having fun with it and so it's then uh
basically uh iarpa brought together this
meeting of personality modelers
to create this book modeling persons and
situations
um basically seeing that the extent
which personality science could do
uh predictive modeling of agents um
basically they want to recapitulate the
plot of westworld as far as i can tell
um so i'm actually not joking
uh but except i am uh but yeah this is
my primarily
uh uh interest
would be just uh what the heck are
persons uh
and uh what can they be and how can we
understand them
and uh who am i and what do i want
yeah and also one thing we haven't
raised is
who or what is a person there's
personality as being the statistical
regularities of
agent in niche so that's just uh
like a person in an exoskeleton you
could have some sort of model for that
or a person with
other types of constraints on or
something like that but
then there's the idea of like what is a
person legally what is a person
culturally and
all these ideas are coming into play
with modeling
legal persons and physical persons and
regular statistical regularities that
include our digital affordances
all of that is becoming integrated our
digital persona is that
included in these uh emotive models
there's just a lot of really interesting
stuff to
think about there so then just copied on
the screen for
people who are looking is that abstract
you can pause the video
there and here is the roadmap then we'll
have the figures and then there's
just one kind of interesting general
question from an audience
but in the roadmap just if you have any
thoughts on
the layout or the authors could give a
point if they wanted to about
why they arranged it the way they
arranged it or which parts they
thought were important if somebody was
just going to read one section or
any thoughts on that otherwise we can
just go to the figures but okay
let me know if you want to return to
this otherwise it's just the headers of
the paper
all right so here's figure one and colin
this really returns to your point from
earlier about the graphical models what
do
connections in graphical models
represent and that's
very related to a general question of
like what do variables
represent principal component one what
does that represent what english word
are we gonna put on that
you know mx plus b linear model what are
we gonna call
x what is the slope what is that going
to be called and then how does that play
out graphically whether in an equation
or whether in a
drawing like this so i would love to
hear your thoughts and then
anyone else can raise their hand on this
one okay so i made the basic distinction
earlier between a
uh a statistical model of covariance
like a structural equation model
i think it's really important not to
call structural equation models causal
models because they're not
that drives me crazy when people refer
to causal modeling and all they're doing
is a set of regression pads
right what that is fundamentally is uh
trying to
you know recreate patterns of covariance
in data
and if you have special kinds of data
like with temporal
priority or where some variable has
actually been manipulated
then you actually interpret you know
causal
effects from covariance structure
but uh just in and of itself there's
nothing inherently causal about
structural equation modeling or
regression
this model here however is different
this is actually intended as a
conceptual
causal model so these are not just
looking at
correlations between different variables
in a population
this is thinking about the actual causal
processes that produce the functions of
an
individual agent specifically a human
being
and so what this is this is just sort of
like a way to encapsulate an overview of
the way that
my theory uh defines personality traits
and characteristic adaptations which are
the two elements of
exhaustive elements of personality uh in
the theory and so the idea is that
you know we know from decades of
research that both genetics and the
environment contribute to
people's personality traits and the
uh idea is that
personality traits are patterns of
behavior that's why they have their own
separate box there there's sometimes a
tendency in personality psychology to
say well what the trait really is is
some underlying thing that causes
people's behavior
but i think that that leads to confusion
because what we actually measure when we
measure personality traits is a
description
of regularities in the person's behavior
and experience
so i think it's important to keep that
clear but then
the the middle box there are the
relatively stable parameters of
cybernetic mechanisms
is trying to say something about where
those patterns of regularity come from
and so the personality traits are not
some underlying causal process that
generates personality they are just
patterns now they themselves do have
downstream causal effects however
because let's say i'm the kind of person
who talks all the time well that's going
to have consequences on the world around
me right and that
will make me lead me to develop
different patterns of adaptation to my
environment to have different outcomes
on the people around me
it's going to lead to different outcomes
and different adaptations so that's the
final
box there um and then they're just you
know there's identification of feedback
loops here so the
idea that you're generally speaking the
flow is that your
basic personality traits caused by these
basic settings of parameters that have a
strong genetic component to them
influence how we adapt and how we do you
know what we pick up on and what habits
we develop in any particular situations
uh habits is a good synonym for
characteristic adaptations
but sometimes there can actually be
feedback so let's say for example
that i'm an introvert but for whatever
reason i get into a job that has a
an important component is selling things
right i get into sales somehow
so i'm going to have to develop at least
in that context the ability to act like
an extrovert if i'm going to be
successful in my job
and maybe i get good at that right so
i've got a characteristic adaptation to
my particular niche which is that at
least in this context
i'm good at acting like an extrovert but
this acknowledges that there's a
possibility for that to feed back and
actually make me more sensitive to
incentive rewards in general
and so i may actually find that i'm not
just more extroverted in this particular
job context
after five years of doing this maybe i'm
more extroverted in my life as a whole
in all these other contexts
um so that's the the one of those
feedback loops and then so you see that
there's a
the environment can directly affect the
kind of ways in which we adapt to our
environment obviously
but the environment but genetics
any effective genetics on our specific
adaptations must feed through the
effects of genetics on these general
mechanisms these parameters that
underlie
our functioning and so you know if
anybody has any other questions about
that
diagram i'm happy to respond
that was a great explanation and just to
um emphasize one point there and then
we'll go to stephen
you said that the characteristic
adaptations and life outcomes are
exhaustive and so um that really is like
we can partition them into the
adaptations or the things that the agent
carries with them
the synapses that have changed or the
scars they bear but basically what
is not their surrounding and the life
outcome is the niche
so then there's this stigma g where the
agent is doing niche construction so
this is from a different
non-active inference non-niche
construction framework but finding
resonances and finding concordances here
because
that's kind of what we talk about like
the learning of agents and then the way
that influences their niche
and then you had this idea of acting as
if like the example with the person
who's
um being forced by their niche to
implement
uh i'm a kind of person who says hello
in this way or
things like that and then that also
relates to what stephen
was saying earlier about drama and about
performance
so maybe stephen do you have a thought
on that
yeah i mean the the the thing i like
about what was mentioned here is how
personality traits
can be adapted
to context like someone's a salesperson
that was a useful example
and then how that obviously starts to
then change your whole
broader way of seeing things and
one area i think might be interesting
and i've been there's the work of harry
hest who's revisiting this
the work of roger barker from the 60s
we did a lot of work on behavior
settings so he looked a whole lot of
children across the us and
he looked at how their behavior was when
they were in a school or in the cafe or
different places he found the difference
in behavior
between settings for the same child was
bigger than the difference in behavior
between
personalities of children ie the same
child
was changing his behavior radically
based on the settings
and that that work kind of got lost but
harry heft has sort of
been really pushing that again i i think
that can tie into this is maybe this
personality traits
are i suppose you know how much
stability there is but
could behavior settings be kind of like
that kind of more dynamic version of
personality traits and i think active
inference
it makes that more possible to even have
that conversation
rather than the more sort of static
psychometric
data which is kind of top down and kind
of
you just have to accept it feels like
this is mo you can get in there and play
with it a bit more
from different directions thanks for
sharing that stephen we'll go
collin and then anyone else who raises
their hands
yeah so that's a really a really good
point steven which is that
uh there is there are differences that
people have to specific situations
that are distinct from their broad
patterns of consistency and personality
and that's a long-running debate in
personality psychology going back to the
to the late 60s and the resolution to it
basically is that yes there are these
relatively stable ways in which people
respond to specific situations
and that's what i'm trying to capture
with the idea of characteristic
adaptations
but then if you go across a bunch of
character a bunch of situations
and you take the person's average there
are also persistent averages that differ
from person to person
and that would correspond to the trait
so you can have both of these things in
the same set of data
and will fleeson is a personality
psychologist who's really been
instrumental in
collecting the data to show this very
basic feature of what are we measuring
when we measure a personality trait with
something like a questionnaire where
we're just asking somebody for this sort
of general impression of themselves
and so what he's done is used experience
sampling methods where
like you have somebody's smartphone and
it you know pings them
like five times a day and asks them like
how have you been acting for the last
you know half an hour
for the last hour and then you get them
to rate their behavior on a set of
uh you know on a set of descriptions or
categories
what you see is that uh as you said
people have as much or even more
variability within their own behavior as
there is variability in terms of their
average behavior from person to person
and yet nonetheless those averages are
quite stable so if you do this for one
week
you can get a whole you'll get a he
calls them density distributions right
you basically just get uh
you know and they're usually fairly
normally shaped um
and you do that for one week you get
this whole pattern so sometimes the
person's acting very introverted
sometimes they're acting very
extroverted you know it ranges
um but there's there's a peak
and that peak is very stable if you do
it again
in another week so the person goes
through another week of behavior and
again they're
varying very widely in their behavior
but if you look at their average level
of that particular behavior
it's quite stable uh over time and so
and then he's also shown that that
correlates quite highly with the
ratings that we get from these general
personality questionnaires
so the questionnaires really are tapping
into this sort of general average
tendency of specific behavior
even though of course the behavior
itself varies widely from situation to
situation and over time
both due to situational affordances and
due to whatever is going on internally
in terms of the goals that the person is
pursuing at that moment
awesome let's go marco then adam
yeah thanks it was actually really
interesting i apologize i'm gonna
add another interesting thing to connect
to so so someone mentioned
steven mentioned the uh the kids in the
classrooms and the context and i think
development might be also very
interesting here
because um personality might be
relatively stable across a lifetime but
but i think
hopefully we can agree that personality
also enriches
um and in in that process of enrichments
and i would also say empowerment
um there's i think you could say a shift
between the
balance of endogenous and exogenous
influence on
an agent's behavioral adaptation or to
its
to its niches um and so there's a
there's a change in the scope
in which the personality uh has a
relatively large influence on the way
they
adapt and i guess i'm just asking
about thoughts on how you might picture
that kind of process of how
personality might actually in the
beginning largely concern yourself with
how to engage with the world such that
it might
internalize that which it normally
co-ops from the environment so normally
you offload a lot of stuff
to behaviorally adapt which might
explain the variation due to environment
but then over time as it does so it
internalizes certain heuristics certain
patterns certain policies
and learn from environments to kind of
enrich its personality
and then extend the scope
of influence from their personality um
yeah i don't know if that makes sense
but
yeah cool thought yeah adam and then
anywhere else
uh so a few thoughts from before and
then um
some thoughts on marco's thoughts um so
the fleece and description of uh
personality
as a kind of uh density uh distribution
um i think and the issue of um the
stability of personality and the
variance of it
with within individuals across context
which is part of the reason the
book that was this chapter was part of
was called
modeling persons and situations but uh
taking these ideas together we're kind
of in the same territory
uh that of these fundamental questions
in the free energy principle
of like what is the ontological status
of
a non-equilibrium steady state
distribution bounded by a markov blanket
um
what's the granularity over which we can
find this
this thing that we're identifying so
it's
you're uh and so
um colin will be able to speak more to
this but this idea of like
there are ways of describing that
your degree of variability across
context
is itself something that can be stable
and this could be itself part of your
personality um
uh now kind of loop back uh to
what you were just describing marco um
i really like that idea um so it's like
you're
you're starting out in a situation
where through this interaction between
you
and this context that you're
entering into in certain ways based on
your own expectations and the
expectations of
people in the environment and the
structures that are there
built up from this there's a certain
stability
and then you both you uh
this stability um ends up shaping you um
both just as a consequence of like this
is the thing for you to predict
but also in the active inferential sense
and as you're saying empowerment
this is what's going to help me get
better purchase
i'm reducing my uncertainty with respect
to realizing the value of uh
existing and so this um
idea that your personality being kind of
um
internalization of structure and maybe
at a certain stage almost like a kind of
amortized inference
um in terms of uh which i got from you
uh uh yeah i really like that idea a lot
cool adam shannon
you're a muted chin
thank you um going on this developmental
thread and um
the paper that you brought up this
morning daniel and
um anna's new paper on the the first
priors
when you're in redo as a baby i haven't
read it
yet but um
the idea that like when you're in a
neonate
in a body you're literally relying on
someone else's
interceptive states and biological
states to regulate
everything about your interceptive and
biological states
and then you're born and you're still
kind of relying
on the caregivers interceptive states or
their behavior when they're holding you
or coming to comfort you
um this i think
could relate to what marco was saying
about how your personality
develops so first if you have if a
personality is something like a
collection of
effective states and behaviors and
an infant is completely sort of reliant
on the environment
and the social environment to regulate
its own
personalities and as you grow through
toddlerhood you slowly are able to
control this yourself like you can
maintain your own body budget a little
bit more
um learn how to how to get your own
blanket if you're cold or
like self-soothed and then you grow
older and maybe you're taught how to
make
music and learning that this is a new
way that you can
explore your personality or create it
um and
i don't study development also sorry if
this is
wondering maybe sasha can pick up on it
but i feel like this
can kind of connect if instead of
looking
or not instead of but in addition to
looking at averages but looking at like
a time series
of personality development over time and
like you could do at any point in time
at any range of time
some sort of um like what would be that
the active reference model of
your life in infancy and toddlerhood
in you know rowdy teenage years and as
adult and you'll have
you'll you'll find these like steady
trajectories
at the same time that was a bit rambling
let me connect that to a few other
points so adam raised this question of
what is the level
of the thing or how do we identify
things from empirical
data specifically so that we can use it
in active inference type or free energy
principle type
models do we use renormalization group
or principal component analysis or
some type of adjacency matrix some type
of markov blanket
what are those things that we're
actually going to be modeling
and that reminds me a lot of a theory
called a n t
uh actor network theory by bruno latour
and then also on the ant wavelength
colin was mentioning how there's so much
variation within
individuals but also stable differences
between
and that reminded me a lot of my
graduate school
work with ant colonies where day to day
the variation across
all the ant colonies was extreme if it
was raining they would do one thing if
it was very dry
versus if it had rain the day before
those were massive determiners of colony
behavior
however across days and even across
years
there were stable markers of colony
behavior and there were characteristic
ways in which they responded
to the environment so it is possible to
have
a type of measurement and understanding
of a system
which my advisor established through
long-term observation
where you can actually model this
development through time
as well as within a population which
doesn't erase individual differences it
actually is the framework
by which individual differences arise
and then change is so beautiful with
music being introduced like a thread
of personality and then that can be used
to explore these regularities
adam and then steven
hi um what was the paper that people are
mentioning uh about like first priors
i'll post it in this jit scene we'll put
it in the youtube chat but let's
continue without worrying about this
paper okay oh
god oh sorry okay should i
join it can i just i was just going to
put in one thing
just um because i like when it mentions
here relatively stable parameters
of cyber naked cybernetic mechanisms the
sort of
those kind of dynamics i think that
links also to this idea of how that
might change during our life
and thinking about our lifetime and
one thing that i'm very interested in is
is when trauma comes into play
ptsd and other types of situations and
you know it's um it can really shift
the state of someone and polyvagal
theory kind of talks to that we've kind
of got the sort of social
co-regulation that we have as humans but
we also have our kind of primal
kind of fight or flight or our gut
sort of sort of fear um responses
and how those things
are in a way another type of like
pattern behavior which becomes
incredibly
stable too stable like you can shut down
or you might get into rage
but then over the period of the day or
life the challenge is
they may it may be unregulated about
when they appear
so someone might sort of be a certain
way and then they flash into rage
you know and then they come come back
into and their personality is radically
different and i think this
is so they might be interesting to bring
in that
that that as a kind of a what happens
when that relatively stable state
itself flips you know so that the
the and it might say your your mechanism
might not be
cognitive but it might be in that kind
of
polyvagal system yes the body
influencing phase transitions in
personality or behavior
adam and then colin and then marca
you're meeting that
thanks um yes i think uh
colin should probably speak to what was
just brought up in terms of like
what actually happens with people um but
in terms of uh
like a high level of abstraction um
so yeah it seems like there's this sense
in which you can think of personality
as a kind of core screening but it's a
kind of renormalization in terms of it
existing as a phenomenon and it's a
an epistemically it's a kind of core
screening um afforded by this
renormalization
um this kind of throwing away a
variability
as you form these higher level
attracting states
um that you can ignore them
within the scope of a certain type of
modeling that you're engaging in
with respect to having certain
objectives of trying to predict certain
things
whether you're a personality modeler
trying to predict someone else or
trying to predict yourself or whatever
um the so within this
um looking for this like optimal
level of epistemic grip in terms like
the granularity of your description
um this
there you could describe these
cybernetic control parameters as being
uh part of the causal process of what's
responsible
and then if you take the system and you
perturb it there's going to be like
a range where like the order parameter
changes you can get these
non-linear maybe phase shifts where the
um
you're now in a different regime and it
may look like a very different kind of
person
because the personality structure as
this
a stable attractor network um
can then become destabilized um and
so that would be like a high level and
college probably speak to like what
actually happens with people
yeah call and go for it so you get these
phase shifts in behavior but they're
often due to persistent sensitivities
in the underlying mechanisms right so
let's take
um also uh ptsd okay
um what you have there essentially is
some kind of traumatic event
uh is an intervention that resets the
sensitivity of the threat systems
and so the that corresponds quite well
to the
big five dimension that's labeled as
neuroticism which is an old-fashioned
word but in this context basically just
means sensitivity to all different kinds
of negative emotion
and so obviously that's heightened in
ptsd and what that means fundamentally
is that you've gone through some kind of
traumatic event
that led to your your it wasn't just
learning about a specific event right
what it did was that it reset the
sensitivity of your threat system as a
whole
so now you are perceiving threats and
reacting with
defensive negative emotion to much more
minor situations than you would have
previously um and of course even in
terms of risk for ptsd we know that
people who are higher in
threat sensitivity to begin with are
more likely to develop ptsd so it's not
like it comes out of nowhere typically
but nonetheless it's obviously this
change and there was a recent really
nice meta-analysis
of personality change following uh
therapy
and different types of psychotherapy
whether it's pharmaceutical or talk
therapy
or cognitive behavioral therapy all of
these lead to changes in personality and
the
the trait that changes the most as you
might expect is reductions in
neuroticism
right so uh what we're talking about
here is the ability to
shift these underlying parameters that
are not
constantly manifest in the same way so
when we say that somebody's high in
trade anxiety for example we don't mean
that they're experiencing anxiety at
every minute of every day at a high
level right we just
mean that they're more likely to be
anxious more intensely
in more situations than somebody who is
low in trade anxiety
but nonetheless then if we really want
to understand the dynamics of the system
we need to understand those phase shifts
from like feelings of safety to feelings
of anxiety at any given moment and i
that's what you're talking about but in
order to understand how that works for a
given agent
we also need to understand these
persistent patterns of the sensitivities
that lead them to have these shifts
in different situations into different
degrees than other asians
very cool thank you marco then blue
thanks um yeah this is really
interesting so um
trying to tie back to the earlier talk
about um
the role of affects to this aspect of
trauma so i think it's mentioned before
by the two authors that that
we could validly see these complex
systems as composed of
a different micro personalities
distributed over scale and levels
um and virus and similarly for affect
in the sense written about uh by cost
per husband and others
so um adam saffron adam also
mentioned renormalization right so so i
think that ties in also to
a lot of different things like stigma g
or equilibration and i think perhaps
it's i had a thought i wanted to share
is maybe maybe
um the clustering phenomenon of
personalities might be
a natural consequence of something like
renormalization or
equilibration if there already is a
certain heterogeneity
if there already is a certain kind of
asymmetry in certain
factors certain basic mechanisms of the
cybernetic
systems to shoot it throughout then that
naturally should cluster
because then they are more likely to
cooperate if it remains
heterogeneous and disordered or not
co-organized then it's inefficient but
then you have this thing with trauma
which i think would disrupt that process
right because
if you go back to the components you
pointed out interpretation
goals and strategy then that's basically
the key things about a trauma right
you're understood in a situation that
just demands an extreme
change in your interpretational beliefs
or models
your goals for a particular situation
and the
extreme pressure to have the right
strategy to get out of it
and i think maybe the the the the side
effect right the byproduct
of that momentary extremeness is that it
basically expands its influence
and so it becomes hypersensitive by
nature and so
the ongoing the always ongoing process
of equilibration of everything
co-regulating
uh becomes disrupted by that one
participant
the traumatic complex um if that makes
sense so instead of a lot of different
personalities kind of equilibrating with
each other
kind of polycentrically it becomes a
monocentric equilibration
if that makes sense it's a bit rambly
lots of very interesting points thank
you blue and then adam
so just to kind of take the trauma
aspect maybe to the
other side of the spectrum and and just
in thinking about
um you know like our own perception of
our self right like so how we hold on to
our
own like personality versus is it you
know congruent with what others think of
us
so i'm thinking you know as how does
this really relate to
um meditation right like so in in
meditation
there's like the idea of getting rid of
the asmita right like so
where like that's the thing that builds
the ego or
like the construct of i so as we like
eliminate this
like construct of i and also like
staying in the moment right like we're
not necessarily trying to build
an accurate predictive model in a
meditation
state so so when we have this like it's
like this dissolution
of of like free energy or or or what is
happening like in in the meditative
state
um that can also bring about a drastic
personality shift i think
as we get get rid of the eye and learn
to be non-reactive
as opposed to like traumatic reaction
that's done non-linear acceleration
awesome adam and then marco then call it
and then anyone else who wants to raise
your hand
hi um so uh
let's try to address a couple of the
threads um
i'll come to meditation uh uh at the end
i think
but the um
it seems like a lot of
the um principles of personality
uh in terms of their generality
could be really interestingly modeled um
actually using things like ant colonies
uh
like in daniel's work um and you might
even find interestingly like even
similar mechanisms at play so like in a
recent paper
starting to do active inferential
modeling of ant colony uh behavior
decisions and foraging um
daniel mentions like you know that
there's like the
was it the foragers have more dopamine
so you could see
things like the functional significance
of dopamine
actually as its way of parameterizing
a cybernetic system as being potentially
similar although potentially switching
across scales
where in the individual ants and maybe
even in the personality of the colony as
a whole
and there's would be actually this
interesting interplay between the
personalities
of individual ants and the personalities
of colonies
and this interplay which might not be in
exactly a one-for-one might
actually even be a kind of um
complementarity where certain
characteristics being present
on um this broader level this this more
encompassing
markov blanket where the individuals are
part of a super organism or just
the organism um from the perspective of
natural selection because the colony is
that which is selected uh
as daniel says um but
so the person out of the colony let's
say um
would then interface and interact with
the personality of
the uh the individuals of which it's
composed
and uh potentially in an in training way
but potentially not
um to loop around um
you might even be able to uh at the
level of
a colony talk about things like the
affect of tendencies that it's
you know it's what is its what is the
affect the valence
the emotions experienced by the colony
as a whole in a given instance
what is its um uh
general mood and then what are its
patterns of mood across
different situations it's and you might
now we're kind of going into
what we more call personality territory
and you could even think of things like
um to kind of bring in some of
like marco's idea of the nature of
trauma in this like dynamic system sense
like
you could traumatize the colony and does
it then at some point like
you would expect some sort of like
elasticity or um what's the term like
hysteresis i don't know not that but it
would be
you perturb it and then it it would have
some sort of adaptive potential to
come back from the perturbation because
that's what
we're trying to do is uh keep existing
in the way we are and see
some adaptive potential but you push it
too far
and then you might not get back this um
adaptive attracting structure you might
get stuck in a different regime
um and you could think of the same
things uh similar things
this could be a way of describing things
that happen within the within uh
individuals like so there's um
you can think of that maybe on multiple
levels of abstraction but stop for now
thanks yep i just switched the slide to
figure two so colin and then marco go
for it
and maybe we can introduce the p-struct
idea or just how does active inference
specifically help us address some of
these questions
but go ahead call and then marco okay
well what i'm
uh my thoughts are about a couple of the
last uh comments so they're
sort of more related to the to the
previous slide and then go ahead then
it's fine
um so in terms of both this discussion
of what's going on in trauma and what's
going on in meditation i think one of
the interesting things to think about
again is the distinction between the
personality traits and the
characteristic adaptations
um because in in both there's the
capacity for both of them to be shifted
so marco was talking about the way in
which in a traumatic event
you are basically pre-existing goals and
interpretations and strategies are
dramatically invalidated and that
you know then means that the system
doesn't know how to pursue its goals in
fact it may not even know what its goals
should be and obviously that's extremely
disruptive and disregulating and so one
of the challenges
in the immediate of course is to figure
out uh what you should be doing what
strategies you should be using
but then there's also this capacity for
that traumatic event uh to
shift the underlying sensitivities of
the system to what is perceived as
disruptive in future right to sensitize
to to the things that disrupt um and
that
is you know obviously an adapted
response to say like if you're in a
dangerous environment you should become
more sensitive
to uh to danger and the traumatic event
just basically taught you that the world
was a much more dangerous place than you
thought that's part of what is
uh tragic about it right because you
have this persistent sense that the
world
potentially is much is much more
dangerous even than it is or that you
should experience it as being
but then you have the same kinds of
dynamics going on in
um in meditation where trying to reduce
your reactivity
that's like trying to shift some of
these basic parameters of
the system so that you you know react
less easily or disrupted less easily
and then the kind of non-eye idea the
recognition of the
the illusory nature of the eye what
that's about is basically not being
overly attached
to your uh model of yourself
right because the model is the model
it's not yourself
so if you are overly attached to your
model then you have you're overly
attached to your conscious understanding
of what your goals and your strategies
are and what you're like
and meditation is basically trying to
get you to
recognize those ideas that you have a
they're just
hey they're just your model they're not
actually the way that you
are and b they're contingent on your
situation and so you should be willing
to let them go as your situation changes
and as things evolve
and so it's essentially creating both a
pattern of greater flexibility
in the capacity to adapt but then also
the attempt to uh down regulate the
negative reaction to disruption right
because if you have more confidence in
your ability to adapt
then you should uh be less defensively
reactive to disruptions because you can
be confident that
you'll simply adapt to whatever the the
new situation is
thanks marco yeah thanks
um yeah just just piggybacking on that
because that was really nice
um yes so so my thoughts on meditation
and very good and important question i
think um
so so going back to the image of having
all these different distributed micro
personalities or some personalities
i think meditation can be seen as
allowing them to manifest and arise as
it often is called
and manifest the expressions which are
always going on
to also reach as a word the global
workspace or consciousness
or the conscious attention and so what
you're doing then effectively is
broadening the collective of sub-agents
or sub-personalities or sub-systems
such that that equilibrative process
improves
because then you have a bigger scope a
bigger domain of possible inputs
to an ongoing process of inference and
importantly this is then
of course without need for explicit
modeling you don't need to explicitly
label
a certain um rashly or verbally
explicated belief
right it's an exercise in in the in the
deepest sense of it
uh importantly it's it's effectively a
reflexive
niche construction because meditation is
systematically to
basically disattenuate to yet to
attenuate external inputs
you sit in a very neutral position you
close you're in a common environment
external input is minimized and so all
the inputs
well it augments the inputs that is
endogenous coming from within
which of course is then going to
translate or transfer
to normal waking states because those
are all the endogenous
or it concerns all the possible
endogenous influences on your ongoing
cybernetics
and so it's it's it's a reflexive shift
right
and yeah i don't know what i was going
to say uh
yeah so it's basically just a starting
at the game so from what i have seen my
limited experience
with meditation and reading upon it it's
all systematic
cybernetic games it puts you in a
situation that that forces you to train
the process to underlie cybernetics
concerning the purely reflexive
which is of course beautiful because
there's almost no opportunity for that
it's an extremely exclusive states of
being
that exclusively force you to attend
to these endogenous processes it's kind
of the cybernetics of this urbanistics
if that makes sense
great points there it's why so much
meditation begins with
thankfulness and just to give actually
one behavioral example
um let's think about the example of a
circus elephant
where when it's young it has a heavy
chain and it can't break away and then
when it's older
a simple thin rope can keep it connected
so at a first pass one might say um
well why doesn't it just break away why
doesn't it engage in a policy of
breaking away
and the habits the e the priors over the
policy the field of affordances
may not even include that as an option
so if certain types of actions
are down regulated so to speak by 100x
before any evidence comes in
then it's going to be interpreted within
a prior that down regulates or basically
down waits the relevance or the
likelihood of certain types of actions
happening
but also there's this element of the
preferences where it may
through whatever mechanism it's not an
exact metaphor here
the system kind of like a stockholm
syndrome situation
the system can actually uh internalize
a preference for certain states that may
or may not be consciously available
during regular states of consciousness
that lead into
the implicit processing of everything
within a framework that results in
behavior that's not
aligned with something else which could
be external niche pressure or
peer pressure or it could be
disconcordant with one's own
narrative themselves and then meditation
is interesting to think about as far as
isolating these different types of
parameters in the model and different
kinds of meditation lots of different
ways to
do it adam
hi um
hard to follow up on all that the um
some of the way the threads came
together for me uh
was it seems like
across varieties of meditation and
why would you do such a thing um and
ultimately like to
bring back marco's point about
empowerment um it's
you want to be more capable in some way
having a better grip
on existence in a particular kind of way
uh
you want to be you have more you want to
have
more degrees of freedom with respect to
the way you're engaging
with the world and
there's a sense in which you can think
of different types of meditation
as either as allowing you to
navigate through cybernetically uh
free energy energy landscapes which can
uh and and also adjust the nature of
these landscapes
such that they are navigable so uh you
can think of something like
and to bring back and uh like something
like trauma
or something like uh the elephant
getting stuck you can think of this as
like a
a getting stuck at a local optimum um
of a potentially jagged free energy
landscape
and so if you can uh let's say reduce
the uh some emotional
uh regulation capacity the ability to
defuse from experience
and keep the gain on positive feedback
loop cycles
of thought and emotion from getting as
high as they might
you might be able to make the free
energy landscape less jagged
the difference is from point to point
it's going to be
you're not going to have these wild
swings and so this might give you
greater latitude
with respect to pursuing more complex
uh policies and actually i hope at some
point we start to discuss some of uh
colin's work on well-being
because i think it docks uh there's a
lot to be said there
um but uh one thing uh
on this one podcast com was mentioning
like you can
think of one of the benefits of
mindfulness
which is like in pursuing any kind of
complex
goal there's going to be a sort of
trading off you're going to have to do
against different things on on route
there
and so if you can like temporarily uh
let some of your character say
adaptation
slide um let's some of your uh policies
like
not be as important if they're if
they're not being if you think they
ought to be realized but they're not
um within some sort of like hierarchical
hierarchical policy selection
well then you can pursue uh you could
hit targets
you wouldn't uh otherwise you could eat
me your mountain car you can get to the
top of the mountain
um in the mountain car problem um
so yeah nice
cool colin and then anyone else i just
wanted to
say to point out that that's that's the
essence of non-attachment right you're
not attached to
particular policies and that means that
you don't get hung up on a sub-goal
when you should be shifting policies
because what you are
trying to pursue is some larger goal
there's sort of you know there's a
stereotype of
uh meditation at least you know zen
meditation for example buddhist
meditation that
you're eliminating your goals right you
have no desires
but that's not that is a that's a
caricature right because it's not that
you have no goals
it's just that you're not attached to
particular low-level goals you might be
uh you know you probably remain attached
to if you're a good buddhist for example
to
eliminating suffering for all beings and
so
it's not like you're not goal directed
and you know you probably
maintain maintain life by eating and
things like this
it's just that you're not attached to
the particular policies that you might
be using
uh to achieve these higher level goals
because goals are just nested i mean
there's a way in which
there's a goal but then the policy is
also just a goal it's just there are
nested goals all the way down to
the terminals which are specific motor
operations or specific cognitive
operations
and so non-attachment is basically
becoming more flexible
in which sub-goals you are willing to
consider and to use
very nice blue so i wonder if it's like
it's more that it's not attachment to
the policy but that actually is the
policy
and it's not attachment to the specific
generative or predictive model i wonder
if that's like
because the policy is then the policy of
non-attachment to the model or
ultimate model flexibility and
right so you could call it a net policy
meta policy
right and and so um and like secondly i
wonder about
uh you know the idea of staying in the
in the present moment
is this like some kind of free energy
equilibrium
like and not necessarily minimization
but like
if we take the generative model and the
predictive model if we take like the
value to zero
are we like is meditation like staying
in the present moment just like this
ultimate state of
of equilibrium in in free energy like
info dynamics
well interesting point about the hyper
prior the bayesian hyper prior and also
that's why a lot of meditation processes
involve
rhythmic or the cessation of other
inputs
because it allows the interoception
potentially to proceed in a different
way
isolation tanks or other altered states
of consciousness so
let's do keeping comments short as well
a few minutes left adam and then marco
in terms of uh there's this one paper
actually that just came out recently but
a model of meditation with respect to
the temporal depth and counterfactual
richness
of uh your generative modeling uh that
just came out i'm
i'll try to find that in sundance but i
think that would speak to this idea of
staying in the present moment
but also this idea of um staying in the
present moment
um also makes me think of this uh
mark was like kind of intimating that
you can think of meditation as a kind of
uh
like game task or almost like a kind of
like
uh maybe maybe play even uh but it's
this building
capacity um that is
building capacity
okay we'll come back mark up four okay
good so
a building of capacity through relaxing
some of your priors and so
letting you to be
informed by policies with respect to
mental acts
that you might not normally deploy and
you might not
normally notice um what is entailed when
you deploy certain types of mental act
so things might
come to mind uh that wouldn't normally
uh that would place you now in into a
different state of
uh affect of inference and so i think
uh if we wanted to do uh modeling of
this of
something like meditation uh we would
want to use
this sort of imaginative policy
selection described by
something like sophisticated affect of
inference
and that would begin to get us there um
the exact way and one more thought
before we move on is
um one more thing i was actually
wondering with respect to
meditation i've talked about this some
with colin is
above the traits in the personality
hierarchy you have these meta traits of
stability and plasticity
and stability
uh is this shared variance over and uh
colin actually uh named these um it's
the shared variance over
neuroticism inverse neuroticism
agreeableness and conscientiousness and
plasticity
is the shared variance over extraversion
and openness intellect
and interestingly the stability seems to
be basically the inverse of
the general psychopathology factor p um
by and large but i think thinking of
mindfulness and meditation
with respect to building capacities for
both stability and plasticity which um
helping to
basically place this so you can think of
stability as
your ability to follow through on and
protect your policies or characteristic
adaptations
and then plasticity would be your
tendency to form new characteristic
adaptations so like whether um
so let's say you do encounter trauma
plasticity
might be what makes the difference so
stability would be how much
it might make sense to the degree to
which you're actually traumatized like
you're very stable
something might you know bounce right
off you you're not traumatized
but let's say you don't have a lot of
plasticity
and that instability is compromised
plasticity is the thing that would let
you update
and uh create
new strategies for being in the world
and
so they're kind of the state of dynamic
tension in that they can like
pull at each other um but they're both
ultimately synergistic and they're like
you're not going to be particularly
plastic unless you have this foundation
of stability and you're not going to be
able to maintain your stability long
unless you're meta stable
and so part of with meditation and
mindfulness i'm wondering if one way of
thinking of it is it's part of what's
actually
really letting you kind of like ride
this optimum of balance stability and
plasticity
and that could be one way of thinking
about part of what um people get from it
cool marco then colin
yeah that's amazing that is a perfect
setup yeah
um i i also fully agree with this theme
of complementarity right so
stability and plasticity sounds it
really resonates with plasticity sorry
openness and focus which is a big
complimentary uh
yeah big polarity in meditation
practices right so if
open meditation and just feel everything
let it all come in etc
focus meditation you know focus on one
point one
mantra um and that
has a bigger connection to the the more
well-known complementary polarity of
exploration exploitation right
but it's not about the polarities per se
it's it's always about the balancing the
math
and for example the sussex said also a
nice paper on that it's
not about perfect theoretical
representations you can have some errors
it's about how you balance everything
off and so again we go back to the
idea notion that meditation can be games
where you
effectively practice balancing that off
because
that balance is not something you can
explicitly verbalize
it's intrinsically pre-verbal because
you can't verbalize maybe the
particular strategies or beliefs
forcibility or for plasticity
but to balance them off is more
effective it's more
flexible or fluid and so the another
interesting maybe duality that you can
think of is also equilibriums
and games or contexts right so in game
theory you have an equilibrium for a
particular game or setting
and so what you said earlier about
equilibrium and staying in the moment
uh regarding meditation i think it's a
very nice idea what adam already said
is that um by being in a particular game
which is that meditative practice
um you will naturally buy free energy
minimization go to a particular kind of
equilibrium
but that necessitates change some
updates and those updates might actually
mean
that your equilibrium seeking behavior
or your attractors will be different
in the other context so the underlying
assumption is that these particular
changes in equilibriums or priors
or attractors are transferable so
um yeah does that make sense as for your
question on meditation presence
playing in the presence yeah cool
thoughts
colin i was just going to say a little
bit more about
stability and plasticity i think that
those can be seen as the two
fundamental needs of any cybernetic
or active inference system that exists
in a complex or changing or
unpredictable environment
and so stability is in some sense just
the the most fundamental requirement
because
the system must be able to pursue its
goals effectively
in order to be a cybernetic system right
if it's an organism that's what it
must have in order to persist and even
an artificial system in order to persist
as the system that it is
it must be moving effectively toward
its goals but then
if you have any degree of
unpredictability in the environment you
can't just be satisfied with the same
set
of policies that you have at any given
time you're going to have to be able to
update your policies generate new
policies
and so that immediately in order to
remain stable over time in a changing
environment
you also have to be somewhat adaptive or
plastic
and so you have these inherent
necessities for the capacity to
maintain a stable order of goal directed
functioning
and then the capacity to generate new
components of the model right new
policies or even new goals or new
interpretations of the
of the situation that you're in and then
those so those are complementary
but they can also they are also in
dynamic tension as adam mentioned
because
if you're massively exploratory it can
be difficult to remain stable because
you have so much
new uh you know information coming in
um similarly if you are well i mean
we've essentially already covered what
the the danger of being too inflexible
and too unexploratory because
you may work fine now but as the
environment changes as things change
over time
then you become unadapted to your
situation
so stability and plasticity aren't
opposite to each other right stability
the opposite of stability is instability
the opposite of plasticity is rigidity
you can be stable and plastic
or stable and rigid you can be unstable
and plastic and unstable and rigid
cool adam go ahead
hi um
it seems like at some point it could be
good to discuss connections
of narrative perspectives on personality
because
this idea of narrative as active
inference
and the work trying to be done there i
think there could be like a rich
interchange because
in some ways you can think of you know
selves as centers of narrative gravity
and you can think of personality as
styles and modes of narration
and themes and motifs as you are this
semi-reliable
narrator telling your story and making
and enacting it and making it so
two degrees um and this being a source
of
to the degree you have stability and
plasticity um
this would be one source of it the
ability of narratives to provide
cross-situational intertemporal common
context
and but also because of their richness
to
create this rich this kind of
their combinatorics and rich
representative capacity
also being a source of plasticity and so
um
narrative being a source of balance
dynamic balancing this dynamic tension
although the narrative itself can also
not be a source of balance but imbalance
if the style of narration becomes
problematic
and so that kind of mindfulness enters
in there again
where um it might suck your usual styles
of
narrative narratorization you might let
that go a bit you go um
this is this is the way in which you go
naive based on your expectations
um yep the stories provide the polls and
the archetypes and then you can say okay
it's like goldilocks
but for the internet of things or
something like that and that gives you a
vocabulary to communicate and design
you might need a very different story in
a very different context and kind of
bring it back to trauma that might be
all the difference between whether
you get stuck or you experience post
traumatic growth
yeah cool interesting and just um one
closing
uh slide that i want to put up while
people prepare their thoughts this is a
question just from
a audience member they wrote i have a
question about what happens when
blankets intersect
blankets of blankets and so let's think
about this in this kind of
blankets of physiologically relevant
states
informationally relevant what what um
think about what we're talking about
here
and at which nodes that would happen and
then there's a link to a
talk by carl firsten and a question
about how nodes intersect
and just while people are thinking about
this or their
last thoughts on the paper one note is
about the scientists and the personality
scientist
as an informational forager as an active
inference agent themselves
and so our quest to reduce uncertainty
about personality
it shouldn't be about the optimal
descriptor it should lead to a question
of ourselves which is what is the
optimal perturbation that we can design
that will reduce our uncertainty the
most about this
individual's personality and so that
takes into account population level
dynamics as a prior but personalized and
um
kind of dynamic testing so imagine
having a baseline prior across knowledge
architectures that people had and then
having a dynamically updating online
course
that was optimally informative from both
sides of the interface it was optimally
informative for what kind of learner the
person was
and they were reducing their uncertainty
optimally about
the topic at hand and so that was like a
co-evolutionary process
amidst a prior that was population level
but personalized in the individual
trajectory
so it's a really interesting framework
in colin adam thanks a lot for
coming on the stream was like really
helpful
and we're excited that you'll come back
for next week so in these last couple
minutes anyone
can raise their hand give a last thought
what would be something that we would
want to
say to this slide about how nodes
intersecting stories intersecting
individuals intersecting
how does that come into play and or what
should we
be thinking about for 13.2 that would be
good to cover
shannon and then anyone else who raises
their hand
i guess i have a thought about um the
question on this slide
um so is um one node that's
a send state and one blanket the
internal state of another blanket
like that's totally the case because
you basically choose the perspective and
whichever
you know blanket sort of internal state
you want to describe or whichever
thing that you're calling the agent
separate from its
environment then that's the
internal state that you're going to
describe and if you're looking at like
if this blue node is a neuron and you
want to actually
know about this pink node this other
neuron's internal state then that's
going to be
your internal state and these other guys
are going to be the sun state the
blanket around it
and that's going to be the statistical
boundary that you're using
to explain the behavior of that neuron
and then
you can aggregate and this collection of
neurons will all be an internal state
for the next collection of neurons so
the answer is in the question that's
exactly right perfect answer
showing that the answer is in the
question is the answer
adam
uh in terms of uh loop around to a
previous thought in terms of uh
nested uh blankets um
and where these different uh blankets
might have different
characteristics and their interaction um
for personality uh there's some
interesting work um
uh column might disagree on titan loose
cultures
where you can think of like the
personality of the culture within
and this tightness and looseness seems
to correspond to this stability
plasticity dynamic tension
this fundamental cybernetic parameters
showing up on the group level
and even theory can get this kind of
complementarity there where a tight
culture
might create more tight um individuals
with respect to
the degree of which you know they let
their their power whether they have a
meta policy of letting their policies
slide more
um in different contexts but uh
or instead of it being this sort of
entrainment relation
it could be a complementary relation
where the stability on the level of the
group
this broader um
attractor affords the fine grain the sub
systems to actually have more latitude
and vice versa
um and i imagine you might probably see
similar things play out like with ant
colonies
um interesting point about multi-level
systems and how they're associated with
relative
constraints in the last two
three minutes let's think of a last you
know if anyone who wants to raise their
hand give a word or
a sentence or few what is something that
you took away
or was exciting today and what was
something that we could
continue talking about in 13.2 and pick
up where we left off
marco and then just anyone else who
raises their hands
yeah i just wanted to thank everyone
this was like really amazing it's my
first
this this kind of stream seminar in ages
so thank you it's innovating
and i think in general what's to be
taken away i think is
excitement because it's kind of amazing
how many different domains and topics
and questions
have been successfully synthesized in
this big discussion and i think that's a
testament
to the power of these kinds of
frameworks of bayesian or active infants
free energy cybernetics
when it comes to understanding us people
us persons personalities
um as individuals as as collectives so
thank you again for exciting me thank
you
well said and the group performance
is uh only realized it's only enacted
even digitally
when the people show up and it's only
relevant when there's the regime of
attention
and so there's so much you know fun and
it's great to have you
um multiple of you on your first time
here that's always appreciated
so any other thoughts in the last minute
otherwise in the calendar invite is a
feedback form
so if you're just wanting to think a
little bit more if you're live
participant you want to think a little
more about what we could cover next week
just
put it in that feedback form and then
anyone who's watching it
just leave a comment for something that
we can address even if it's after 13.2
maybe we can swoop back and return to
some previous comments but
this was a super fun discussion and a
big thanks to all the participants
so really good times everyone and thanks
a lot
so see you next week